[Música]
Está girando hacia ti o se aleja no hay
acuerdo ella es el tema misterioso del
maestro holandés Johannes bernier la
joven de la perla una pintura que se
suele Llamar La Mona Lisa del Norte
en un estilo holandés de pinturas
idealizadas a veces demasiado expresivas
conocido como tronics la joven de la
perla tiene El Encanto y la
característica sutileza de la obra de
bernier pero esta pintura se distingue
de las escenas narrativas tranquilas Que
observamos de lejos en muchas de las
pinturas de vermier una joven que lee
una carta una clase de piano un artista
del retrato en acción estas pinturas nos
dan un sentido de intimidad mantienen su
distancia una cortina corrida a menudo
hace hincapié en la separación podemos
ver una lechera que vierte serenamente
un tazón de leche pero esa leche no es
para nosotros la composición estudiada
en las pinturas de vermier invoca una
armonía equilibrada con el piso a
cuadros en Muchas de sus obras bernier
demuestra su maestría en la perspectiva
y el escorzo es una técnica que usa la
distorsión para dar la ilusión de un
objeto que se aleja en la distancia las
líneas de visión los espejos y las
fuentes de luz describen el momento
mediante el espacio y la posición la
mujer que lee una carta en una ventana
abierta está ubicada para que la ventana
refleje su imagen al espectador
ocultó la pata de un caballete en aras
de la composición
la ausencia de estos mismos elementos
dan vida a la joven de la perla el
tratamiento que vermir da a la luz y a
la sombra El claroscuro usa un fondo
oscuro plano para poner de relieve su
tridimensionalidad en vez de ser como la
escenografía de una escena narrativa
teatral se torna un sujeto psicológico
el contacto visual y sus labios
entreabiertos como a punto de decir algo
Nos atraen a su mirada los temas
tradicionales del retrato eran figuras
nobles o religiosas Entonces por qué
dormir pintó una joven anónima en el
siglo 17 la ciudad de delft como los
Países Bajos en general se había vuelto
contra la aristocracia gobernante y la
Iglesia Católica
tras ocho décadas de rebelión contra el
poder español los holandeses
favorecieron la idea del autogobierno y
una República política
ciudades como delft no eran supervisadas
por Reyes u obispos por eso artistas
como vermier se quedaron sin clientes
tradicionales
pero la innovación empresarial
encabezada por la compañía holandesa de
las indias orientales transformó el
panorama económico
creó una clase mercantil y un tipo de
patrón que deseaba ser representado en
las pinturas que financiaba estos
comerciantes preferían sujetos de clase
media representados en espacios que
parecían sus propios hogares rodeados de
objetos familiares los mapas que
aparecen en las pinturas de vermiere por
ejemplo eran considerados mundanos y a
la moda por los comerciantes de la edad
de oro holandesa
el turbante Oriental que lleva la joven
de la perla también hace hincapié en la
mundanidad de la clase comerciante y la
perla en sí un símbolo de riqueza es en
realidad una exageración
No se podría haber permitido una perla
De ese tamaño quizá fue una cuenta de
vidrio o de lata barnizada para
asemejarla
ese Espejismo de las riqueza se refleja
en la propia pintura en un contexto más
amplio aparece la perla redonda y pesada
pero una vista detallada muestra que es
solo una mancha que flota en la pintura
un examen minucioso recuerda el poder de
vermier como creador de ilusiones
quizá nunca conozcamos la verdadera
identidad de la joven de la perla Pero
podemos abordar su retrato de una manera
inolvidable
desde su hogar permanente en el Museo
maurie House en la haya su presencia es
a la vez penetrante y sutil
a su manera enigmática representa el
nacimiento de una perspectiva moderna
sobre la economía la política y el amor
[Música]
si deseas seguir explorando el mundo del
arte y los artistas vea este video sobre
la vida y el arte de la pintora
surrealista mexicana Frida Kahlo
[Música]